nos dicen que el cuadrado de abajo
representa un entero este cuadrado
completo es un entero y nos preguntan
qué porcentaje representa el área
sombreada pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo
vamos a ver el entero está dividido en 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 secciones iguales de
las cuales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 están
coloreadas esta es el área sombreada
entonces una manera de pensar en esto es
que siete décimos están sombreados pero
como expresamos esta fracción como un
porcentaje nos preguntan por el
porcentaje bueno recuerden que el
porcentaje literalmente significa por
ciento ciento tiene la misma raíz que la
palabra 100 lo vemos en centavos o
centenario y podríamos escribir esto
como sobre 100 en lugar de sobre 10
bueno 7 sobre 10 es lo mismo que 70
sobre 100 y esto es lo mismo que 70 por
ciento y como llegamos
sobre 100 a partir de 7 sobre 10 bueno
simplemente multiplicamos el numerador y
el denominador por 10 y si haces más y
más porcentajes vas a obtener práctica
podrás decir o 7 décimos es lo mismo que
70 sobre 100 que es igual a 70% hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nos dicen que en el
siguiente diagrama de cinta se muestra
el 100% entonces esta cantidad que
tenemos aquí es el 100% y nos preguntan
qué porcentaje está representado por el
diagrama de cinta completo tenemos que
decir qué porcentaje representa todo
esto que tenemos aquí pausa en el vídeo
y traten de encontrar la respuesta bueno
una manera de pensar en el 100% es que
equivale a un entero y tenemos 3 veces
esa cantidad en el diagrama de cinta
completo de modo que tenemos 3 enteros o
podríamos decir que este es el 100% aquí
tenemos otro 100% y aquí tenemos otro
100% así que el diagrama de cinta
completo representa
a 300 por ciento
hagamos otro ejemplo el rectángulo
grande de abajo representa un entero muy
bien todo esto representa un entero qué
porcentaje representa el área sombreada
pausa en el vídeo nuevamente y traten de
resolverlo para empezar dejen de
expresar esto como una fracción tenemos
un total de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 cuadros de los
cuales seis están sombreados tenemos
seis veinteavos podemos expresar esto
como por ciento vamos a ver para ir de
20 a 100 tenemos que multiplicar por 5 y
si multiplicó el numerador por 5
obtendré el mismo valor 6 por 5 es igual
a 30 así que 6 por 20 es lo mismo que 30
sobre 100 lo que equivale a 30 por
ciento que literalmente significa por
100 así que esto es 30 por ciento
hagamos un último ejemplo
nos dicen que cada uno de los
rectángulos grandes de abajo representa
un entero
este es un entero y este es otro entero
qué porcentaje representa el área
sombreada nuevamente pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo en este entero
tenemos todo sombreado así que esto
representa el 100% y en éste tenemos
sombreado 1 2 3 4 quintos del entero así
que si queremos expresar cuatro quintos
como por ciento como sería bueno 5 por
20 es igual a 100 y 4 por 20 es igual a
así que aquí tenemos sombreado cuatro
quintos y ochenta sobre 100 lo que es lo
mismo que 80% entonces esto que tenemos
aquí representa el 80 por ciento
qué porcentaje representa el área
sombreada bueno tenemos 100 por ciento y
luego tenemos 80 por ciento así que el
resultado es 180 por ciento es más que
un entero si tienen un porcentaje que es
mayor que 100 por ciento están hablando
de algo que es más grande que un entero
y lo podemos ver aquí este es un entero
y luego tenemos 80 por ciento más
terminamos